monsieur le sénateur luo vous avez posé
beaucoup de questions je vais essayer de
répondre
du coup de manière rapide un maximum
d'entre elles se j'ai d'abord que la
france est le pays des études cliniques
j'en ai cité une tout à l'heure sur la
nicotine il y en a beaucoup qui sont en
course solide roxy chloroquine mais la
france n'est pas la seule pays à
expérimenter l'hydroxyde rockin les
états unis d'autres pays européens et
les dernières publications monsieur le
sénateur que je vous invite à lire qui
ont été publiés et validé ne sont pas en
faveur
hélas mais clairement pas en faveur de
l'utilisation en pratique courante de ce
traitement en mono ou en bithérapie
associé à lisandro micinn néanmoins des
études continue son ensemble du
territoire national dans les hôpitaux
et donc nous aurons des réponses
également issues d'études françaises
mais lisez la publication américaine
d'hier
je vous invite à beaucoup de prudence
encore plus qu'avant encore beaucoup
minci il n'ya pas le protocole docteur à
outils un médicament comprend quand on
est malade et qui est efficace ou qu'il
n'est pas après on peut dessiner ce que
c'est qu'un protocole clinique mais je
vous assure que un protocole ni qui les
y répond à des règles universelles de
publications scientifiques
internationales et qu'en l'occurrence
les publications qui sortent si vous en
trouver une qui est validée qui permet
d'étendre la prescription je serai
encore une fois le plus ravi des miss de
la santé parce qu'on aurait un
traitement efficace ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et c'est mon rôle de le dire
sur les laboratoires vétérinaires
monsieur le sénateur ils ont été
mobilisés ils ont proposé à être
mobilisés passer de la médecine
vétérinaire la médecine humaine c'est
une première dans notre pays et elles
été faites notamment grâce à la
mobilisation des ars et notamment des
préfets sur les évacuations sanitaires
je ne voudrais pas qu'on retienne je
n'aimerais pas qu'on retienne des
évacuations sanitaires
un bus qui a été emporté d'un hôpital à
un autre sans prévenir les autorités de
santé j'aimerais qu'on retienne que
notre pays a réalisé six cent quarante
quatre évacuations sanitaires par train
par avion par hélicoptère nous sommes le
seul pays au monde à l'avoir fait c'est
une fierté française
j'étais en lien hier avec des
réanimateurs de l'hôpital de strasbourg
qui me racontait ce que savait
représenté comme chantier monumental
pour permettre de sauver des vies c'est
un motif de fierté et nous n'aurions pas
pu le faire sans interventions
permanentes des agences régionales de
santé et de ses agents j'ajoute qu'un
certain nombre d'entre eux ont payé un
lourd tribut il ya eu des morts dans les
ars
monsieur le sénateur et des gens qui ont
continué de travailler alors qu'ils
étaient malades parce que sans les
agences régionales de santé sans leurs
agents dans les territoires tout est
perfectible
tout système surtout administratif
perfectible et je pourrais écrire un
roman sur les difficultés les longueurs
les problèmes logistiques administratifs
que connaît notre pays comme d'autres
mais encore une fois un concours de
rendre hommage au grand talent il ajouté
et enfin sur les dents tissu leurs
écrits hier ils devront cent cinquante
mille masques ffp2 supplémentaires
question pour les remercier pour s'être
organisés pour assurer les urgences sur
tout le territoire depuis plusieurs
semaines milices pour les semaines à
venir il se porte lui rend et après je
vous parlerai du charbon bactéries dhien
c'est un vétérinaire qui l'a mis au
point au 19e siècle
mais monsieur le haut oui monsieur le
ministre le 11 mai on va passer d'une
guerre de tranchées à une guerre
d'action il va falloir être prêt et je
ne suis pas sûr qu'on soit prêt le 11
mai